[Music]
James at 15 star Lance Kerwin has died
he was 62 years old
wait a minute you got this whole thing
all wrong I'm I'm just a normal human
being
the actor's daughter confirmed the news
on Facebook revealing her father died on
Tuesday no cause of death was included
in her message
she wrote we appreciate all the kind
words memories and prayers that have
been shared he loved each and every one
of you
I'm James
former Child Star Kerwin was best known
as James from the 70s TV series
proud that you go around with determines
the kind of person
grew up to be
about a crowd I don't have any crowd he
also landed roles in Little House on the
Prairie and several made for TV movies
The Winds of Revolt sweat Township of
Jerusalem's lot soon to be known
and many remember Kerwin from his
performance in Salem's Lot a mini-series
adaptation of Stephen King's classic
horror Tale foreign
[Music]
go away